all right
let's get started um today we're going
to continue our discussion of
international trade
i want to finish up discussing
comparative advantage
and then we'll talk about the welfare
implications of the economic of
international trade
and then how that drives our thinking
about trade policy one of the hottest
topics in economics discussions today so
let's finish our discussion of
comparative advantage
that we started last time um remember
the key
lesson from the ppf type analysis we did
last time
is that if there's comparative advantage
it can yield
gains to trade through specialization so
that's sort of the key
lesson is that comparative advantage
yields
gains from trade
through the mechanism of specialization
okay so basically careful advantage
because it becomes a comparative
advantage you can specialize and that
means you can essentially get
an outward bending ppf you can
essentially get economies of scope
by specializing in sort of combining
your activities now
you're not literally getting economies
of scope because each person's doing
their own thing
but it acts as if the economy is a whole
is yielding economies of scope because
basically by specializing
you're allowing the economy as a whole
to benefit from people doing what
they're best at
so that's the basic intuition of the
sort of
economics of why international trade can
yield gains
okay now that raised the natural
question of well where does comparative
advantage come from
why do some places have why do some
countries have comparative advantage we
know what comes from me versus lebron
james
he's got better genes and he's worked
harder than i have but basically
when it comes to countries how does um
where does comparative advantage come
from and basically comes from roughly
speaking two sources
the first source of comparative
advantage is factor endowments
some countries just through the nature
of geography and geological history
are endowed with with things that people
want
and therefore gives a power of advantage
in trading those things so if you think
about canada
um canada is endowed with enormous
amounts of forested land
and they've become a major exporter of
uh lumber and paper products over time
that's their comparative advantage
because they happen to have all this
forested land around um so for example
that's why most clothing today comes
from
china and less developed countries
because their compa their factor
endowment is cheap labor
okay it's not that they have more
natural textile threads or whatever
it's just they they have they have a
cheap labor which is the cheap
the primary factor which goes into
producing textiles
so one source of tech of comparative
advantage is factor endowments
now once again some country could have
more of everything canada could have
cheap labor and lumber
but the key point is in the simple sort
of two by two world we're thinking of
it's all about relative comparative
advantage so it's the one that had the
most of relevant to other countries
okay and the second source of
comparative advantage the second reason
why some countries have higher advantage
is technology
so if you look at japan and cars
there's no japan has no comparative
advantage of producing cars
it's not like they have more of the raw
products that make steel than say the us
does
the difference is that japan was a
leader in developing technology of the
modern automobile
and that technological boost gave the
comparative advantage
so factor endowments are kind of natural
technology
is a sort of created source of
comparative advantage
that essentially by developing the
technology
you give yourself really sort of a first
mover advantage
and are able to then um have leadership
have the relative competitive advantage
in producing that good
that's why in some sense it becomes
technology policy really becomes trade
policy and we'll talk about that
uh at the end of the lecture we talk
about trade policy in the u.s
okay so that's really all i just want to
finish up my comparative advantage the
main things the intuition we developed
last time
but just want to highlight also what it
means what comparative edge means and
where it comes from
what i really want to focus on today is
the welfare implications of
international trade and why economists
are such big fans of international trade
so the welfare welfare in trade
and why do economists in simple
diagrammatic form
so uh such strong proponents of
free international trade okay so to
consider that let's go back to our
example of roses and look at figure 191
okay we have here a simple
representation of the domestic market
for roses
okay you've got a supply curve and a
demand curve
and you yield your consumer and producer
surplus
okay so let's say this is for the u.s
you've got u.s supply of roses u.s
demand for roses consumer producer
surplus
now let's ask what happens once we allow
international trade
once we allow for the importation or
exportation of roses
let's go to the next figure which is
pretty complicated so let's walk through
it
okay now we're looking at the rose
market with
imports okay now
the presence of imports in imports don't
act
doesn't actually change the nature of
demand and supply so the domestic or u.s
demand and supply curves are not shifted
what imports do is effectively increase
the supply curve of roses available to
u.s consumers
by adding roses from other countries
okay so what we do is to make this work
what we basically the
the trick we use in these models is we
essentially assume that in international
markets
there's a perfectly elastic supply of
the good
so what we say is international trade
creates a perfectly elastic supply
of rows at the price p sub w that is the
price used to be p sub a for autarky
that's the price where domestic supply
domestic demand
we're going to assume that what
international trade does is lower the
price
to p sub w and make supply perfectly
elastic that is the u.s can get
as many roads as it wants at a price p
sub w
now for a small country this sort of
makes sense
right for a small country essentially
they're like a small producer in a
perfectly competitive market
for the us it might not make so much
sense the u.s is sort of
kind of big enough that it's hard to
imagine that we're sort of price takers
with respect to anything
we're the u.s we don't take any prices
uh
but for in principle the basic intuition
we get from this model works so we're
just going to sort of treat us as a
small
small country for these purposes so and
for something like rose is probably not
bad
to think of the us as a price taker in
the rose market
okay so it's a bit of a cheat to say the
us faces perfectly elastic supply
in the world market but it's not a bad
sheet and it doesn't and it doesn't
hurt the important intuitions will
derive so we're going to assume the us
faces a perfectly elastic world supply
at price p sub w now what we
what does this do what this does is
suddenly at that lower price p sub w
consumers now want
c sub t they want a lot more roses
because the price has fallen demands
downward sloping
but domestic producers want to produce a
lot fewer roses
since marginal cost is upward sloping if
you're going to force the price down to
p sub w
they don't want to produce as many roses
they only want to produce q sub t
how to resolve this you resolve this
through imports
that the difference between q sub t
and c sub t is imports
so the total amount of roses consumed
does rise
from q sub a to c sub t the total amount
of roses consumed does rise
but the amount produced domestically
falls
so both things are happening both u.s
consumers are consuming more roses
and u.s producers are producing fewer
roses and the gap
is made up by imports okay kind of a
complicated diagram are there questions
about this
because i'm going to build on this
diagram going forward any question about
how this works
okay now let's ask what are the welfare
implications
let's go to figure 19-3
what are the welfare implications of
international trade well
the welfare implications are for
consumers their
surplus used to be
um their surplus used to be w
they used to get q sub a roses at a
price p sub a
so their surplus used to be the area w
what is the surplus of domestic
consumers let me an important point for
welfare
we're going to look at domestic
welfare only we'll come back later to
caring about the rest of the world but
for now we
only care about the u.s so when i talk
about welfare unless i say otherwise i'm
thinking about
u.s welfare only u.s consumers u.s
producers
very important to keep in mind because
otherwise this can get confusing so for
now domestic welfare only
so for u.s consumers what has happened
they used to get a surplus of w what's
their surplus now
yeah yes z by the way is the entire sort
of light purple area
it's confusing because there's this
dotted line down the middle z is either
side of the dotted line the entire
triangle is z
so consumers now get w plus x plus c
why because they're consuming c sub t at
a price p
sub w okay don't let the other
complication of the graph confuse you
remember consumer surplus is just the
area
below the demand curve above the price
at the equilibrium quantity the new
equilibrium quantity consumed is c sub t
the new price is p sub w so they get
that giant triangle
producers used to have a surplus of
x plus z x plus y i'm sorry
producers used to sell q sub a
at a price p sub a so the area above the
supply curve
below the price was x plus y
now x has been transferred to consumers
so producer surplus has fallen to why
so what's happened well it's the
opposite of the kind of deadweight loss
diagrams we saw before
when we did things like compose attacks
we transferred
from one group to another creating
deadweight loss
international trade is the opposite
effect we've transferred from one group
to another
and created social gain for the u.s
u.s consumers have gained they've in on
net
us society is better off by the area z
and this in the terms of this course is
why economists like international trade
that expands the opportunity set
by allowing consumers to get these
cheaper goods
you raise consumer surplus more than you
lower producer surplus
and that's why we like international
trade it's a net win for society
now different parties might feel
differently about it we'll come back to
that
but let's just focus right now on total
social surplus
and for total social surplus we're
defined as producer plus consumers
we are better off okay and that's why we
like international trade
okay question about that yeah
the new surplus is just y it used to be
y plus
x so producers are losing x consumers
gain that x but consumers also get z
so sort of the flip side of deadweight
loss we talked about before
you're transferring from producing
consumers but you're also creating new
gains for consumers along the way
okay okay so now that's imports what
about exports
let's flip and think about computers
let's go to figure 19
4 and talk about computers
for computers once again we start at
point a
we start with computers under autarky
without trading the price is where
domain equals supply
at p sub a and the quantity is q sub a
and that's the initial equilibrium for
computers
now we open up to trade well what
happens now
is now the rest of the world wants u.s
computers
so the u.s can sell at a higher price
before the u.s could only sell to
domestic consumers
but now they can their demand for their
goods worldwide
we don't show world demand here but
world demand is way above u.s demand
okay if you flip back to 1903
the reason that that piece of w line is
below the piece of a
is that world supply or 1902 is easier
world supply is below is above u.s
supply
since supply is higher the price falls
now in 1904
world demand is higher than u.s demand
so the price rises so we end up with a
piece of w
at the higher level what does this mean
with a higher p sub w domestic consumers
want fewer computers they used to be
able to buy computers a piece of a
now they have to pay p sub w because
they're competing with consumers around
the world
okay so i have to pay more so they want
fewer computers their demand for
computers falls from qa to ct
what about domestic producers well now
they're getting a higher price so they
want to make more computers
so their production fault rise from qa
to qt
so you now have consumers consuming much
less than producers are making
so the producers send the rest abroad
and that's
exports okay
so we have the flip side before we had
under in figure 19 2 if you flip back
and forth
in figure 19 2 we had consumers
wanting more than producers domestically
willing to make so you had imports
now we have consumer domestic consumers
wanting less
than domestic producers are willing to
make so you have exports
what are the welfare implications go to
19 5.
now what you get is consumers
are worse off they used to have a
consumer surplus of w
plus x where x is the entire dotted area
now that consumer surplus has fallen to
just w remember we're doing domestic
consumers only
there's some people in columbia got
computers they're happy we're ignoring
them
we're just doing u.s consumers okay they
used to get w
plus x now they only get w below the
demand curve above the new price
but producers who used to get y
now get y plus x plus z
so you've transferred x from domestic
consumers domestic producers but you've
also given domestic producers extra bit
z
so once again surplus has gone up
this is the crazy thing about trade
imports
raise welfare and exports raise welfare
either way whether the goods are coming
in or the goods are going out society's
a whole is better off
why because of comparative advantage
because we're better off as a world
where we can share our goods across
nations because we can then rely on the
more efficient producers
lowering the prices for roses in place
like the us
and raise the lowering the prices for
goods us consumes
and raising the price for goods us
produces and same with every
other country it's literally a win-win
every country by the game to specialize
gets to see lower prices and the goods
they weren't good at making
okay and higher prices the goods they
are good at making
so there's transfers across producers
and consumers but overall
uh welfare goes up okay
so basically this is the bottom line
this so these two graphs
are kind of why economists unambiguously
traditionally traditionally constantly
basically like free trade to get into
subtleties like caring about producing
first consumers separately
basically the logic of last time which
is a comparative advantage allows
specialization
means that by trading we can allow
countries to specialize
and thereby getting higher prices of
things they send abroad and lower price
of the things they bring in from abroad
okay questions about that
okay and we can see from this why the
notion of sort of a trade deficit
something we should care about is sort
of ridiculous
because basically it's all just about
your endowments okay at the end of the
day
you want to sell stuff that you're in
doubt you have a competitive advantage
in
and import stuff you don't have a
comparative advantage in if the rest of
the world has more
advantage than you then you want to
import more than you export doesn't mean
you're worse off it just means your
consumers are benefiting
from the fact the rest of the world is
good at making stuff like sweaters
so that segues us naturally to our
important policy discussion and sort of
the main focus one of the main focus of
public policy today
which is trade policy how do we take
this framework and apply it
to thinking about government policy over
international trade and that's what i
spend the rest of today talking about
so let me just before i go there any
questions about the economics here
before we start talking about policy
okay now
trade let's start once again with trade
policy with sort of the standard
economics view
okay which is that you'll often hear
people say well imports are a job killer
and in some sense they're right that's
what figure 19 3 is showing
producers are the ones with the jobs
producer surplus is falling
so there's less profitability in the
corporate sector
so there may be less jobs there
okay now many people say we should react
to that
by imposing restrictions on imports
they say look exports are great but what
about imports they're killing jobs
why don't we restrict those and there's
two fundamental forms of restrictions on
imports
there's quotas which is literally a
limit on how much of a certain good you
can import
those aren't used so much anymore the
more typical form of international
of import deterrence is tariffs
okay it's tariffs okay
and basically what these are are taxes
that are levied only on imports a
tariff is just a name for a tax that
only applies to imports
okay that's what a tariff is it's a it's
a certain kind of tax only applies to
imports
okay so we could for example levy a
tariff on roses coming in from colombia
if we levy that tariff making roses
expensive enough
then folks might go by back to buying
them from the u.s producers and we can
reopen those greenhouses the jobs that
come with them
that is true what that misses the fact
that u.s consumers then
suffer from paying higher prices for
roses
and on net we're worse off as a result
to see that
let's go to figure 19 6.
okay so basically
what figure 19 6 does is
we now start from the position of being
in
international trading so before the
other figures we started from autarky
and added trade
now i want to start from position with
trade and add a tariff so initial
equilibrium
is at p sub w with consumers consuming
c1
producers producing q1 an initial level
of imports
denoted by imports before tariff okay
that's where we start
what the tariff does is essentially
raise the price
back up now i can't raise the price
above the domestic price because if the
tariffs big enough you just go back to
buying what you want for domestic
producers
but it raised it back towards the
domestic price so let's say for example
the tariff is high enough that the
international that the world price the
price paid in the u.s
rises from pw to pt the gap being the
amount of the tax
so with untaxed trade the us would pay
pw for roses
now when we tax trade that price goes up
to p sub t
okay so now let's ask
what does that do to the market well
it's
pretty straightforward you just say well
what is demanded supply at that new
price
what that new price there's lower demand
for roses so rose demand falls from c1
to c2
there's more domestic production of
roses so domestic production rise from
q1 to q2
and the imports after the tower shrink
massively the tariff had its desired
effect
it shrunk imports but what does this do
to welfare
let's go to figure 19.7
now we don't now we can just compare
this area between the two horizontal
lines we used to be at the bottom
horizontal line now with the higher one
a the area a
is the new producer surplus
producers used to get the area that low
triangle below area a
we used to call it y now they've added a
producers have now added a new producer
surplus a
but consumers have lost
a b c and d that entire area is lost for
consumers yeah
comparison to when there was uh
yeah that's what i said comparison where
there was when there was free trade no
tariffs so it's a comparison to
the second situation in figure
19 uh 19 19-3
so 19-3 this is confusing i'm sorry
about that but it's too hard to put on
one graph
19-3 is what happens when we move from
no trade to free trade 19-7
6-7 are moving from free trade to free
trade with the tariff
okay by the way if the tariff was
brought us exactly back to the no trade
situation just be the flip of the
previous diagrams
which makes it a little more interesting
by making the tariffs somewhat lower
than that
so what's happened to consumer surplus
well look at this way remember consumer
surplus
it's the area below the demand curve
above the price
so it used to be a huge triangle now
what's happened is
fall fallen by the entire trapezoid a b
c d
can folks see that look at the new
consumer don't ignore the fact it's four
different areas just think of it as one
trapezoid
the new consumer surplus the area under
the main curve above
pt the old consumer surplus area under
the demand curve above pw
that's followed by the trapezoid abcd
now why do we split that into four
pieces well
first of all because a is gained by
producers so we want to call that out
that's not a net loss in welfare
there's also the area c the green area c
c is also a gain what is c that's the
government revenue from the tariffs
okay the government's gained something
from that we get tax revenue
okay we could give that back to
consumers if we want so that's not lost
surplus
the tax revenues exactly the amount of
new imports
times the tariff so it's complicated
it's not now we have this third player
which is a government used to be just
either producer consumer or or society
now we have the third player which is
the government
so the deadweight loss from the tariff
is b plus d what we've lost
is b plus d so let me go through the
math again consumers lost
a plus b plus c plus d
producers gained a and the government
gains c
so the net loss from the tariff is b
plus d
okay that's sort of hard but people see
that
and that's why economists don't like
tariffs
because the amount producers gain
plus the amount the government raises is
much less than what consumers lose
yeah we've created some jobs growing
roses yeah we've gotten a little tax
revenue
but we've really screwed producers who
have to pay much higher prices for their
roses
and if you add that up it's worse why is
it worse because you're taking less
advantage of specialization comparative
advantage
by forcing us away from the most
efficient point
the most efficient points we can take
everyone can specialize you force that
away
you've put the u.s which shouldn't be
growing roses back in the business of
growing roses
and colombia which should be growing
roses gets out of that business
yeah um
are they like on like us i guess
like receive goods or are they like on
uh yeah so
that's a great question i am not expert
on the actual logistics
but roughly speaking when it comes into
the us
into customs so any good shift in the
u.s for sale into customs
at that point there is a tax levied on
it now i don't know logistically who
gets the bill
does the exporting company get the bill
or the importing company get the bill
um when we talk about taxes i'll show
you it doesn't matter who gets the bill
it's the same either way okay so hold
that thought but that's basically what
happens
question okay so with that in mind
okay so that is the fundamental reason
in graphical terms
why economists don't like tariffs but
that's not the only reason
in fact there's two other reasons that
aren't even in this graph
why tariffs and restrictions on trade
policy more generally are bad
the other reason is that they cause
trade wars
okay so let's say that um let's say we
impose this tire for colombian roses
well columbia will be like screw you if
you're going to tax our roses we're
taxing your computers
well what would happen if there was a
tariff that columbia placed on our
computers
well i don't have that figure but you
should be able to show yourself
that that is exactly the opposite effect
it raises u.s consumer surplus because
now computers are cheaper in the us
because we can't sell them in colombia
but it lowers our welfare and now we
don't get the government revenues
colombia does
so we lose almost all the trapezoid in
that case
if you flip this around we would get a
small rise in consumer surplus but a
huge loss of producer surplus and we
wouldn't even get the government
interviews to make it up
so that's really bad for us and of
course it's a natural response why
wouldn't colombia do it
okay so this this first problem is this
understates
yes we might create some jobs and roses
but we're going to destroy jobs and
computers
because we're not going to sell as many
computers as we used to so it's not even
job creating
okay this once you take in the fact that
other countries retaliate
in fact we make consumers worse off and
producers worse off
because make the price for roses much
higher and we lose jobs in the computer
sector
so basically one way to do is to come to
trade deals where you essentially
essentially cartelize countries so this
is much if you can think of this in very
parallel ways to a non-cooperative
oligopoly
if you can cooperate what do you do you
just get to free trade
and that will talk about trade deals in
a few minutes that's essentially what
those are doing
so so let me get to that okay so
basically
um what we've done and let me ask the
first question basically what we've done
is
because of the arguments i've made here
over time we've created essentially
cooperative
oligopolies around the world pro the one
you've heard a lot
is uh uh okay so i'm sorry trade wars
this is the first let me second reason
the second reason is that actually as
decent human beings we might care about
people in other countries too
okay and the fact is that
there's when you these both import
restrictions
and trade wars hurt other countries just
like they hurt us
so we worse off but other countries are
worse off even without the trade war
we've met ourselves off and we've heard
colombia because they can't sell our
roads to the roses to the u.s
the other reason we don't like so the
other reason besides this figure
is that basically if we if we place any
weight at all on the utility of people
outside the u.s
which we should okay it's bad as well
now i'm not saying you have to wait a
colombian colombian's welfare the same
as u.s welfare but as long as it's
non-zero
then that's the second reason to oppose
it and that's why there's been a huge
growth in agreements the most famous of
which
we we've heard of is nafta the north
american free trade agreement signed in
the early 1990s under president clinton
which essentially set up a cooperative
oligopoly between the u.s
mexico and canada such said let's just
get rid of these trade barriers so we
can have freer trade within
within our regimes okay
and basically um but
this was uh this was actually you know
quite popular time economists liked it
but it's become very unpopular over time
was opposed by president trump and in
fact he originally ripped up nafta
although he replaced with something
that's pretty much the same uh just
renamed it as
usmca uh so why are people you know
why are people so opposed to free trade
it's a great question why are trump's
advisors why in fact
are the majority the majority of
americans have having asked the question
don't like free trade you know it
depends i ask the question but it's
certainly not universally popular like i
said it should be
so what's going on okay well
there's really a couple things going on
the first
is that we can't we don't i wouldn't say
can't
we don't compensate the losers
this is the most important part
we don't compensate the losers what do i
mean by that let's go back
to figure 19
uh three
what's happened we've put an
international trade
producers have lost x
consumers have gained have gained x and
z
so it's a simple economic policy if we
did international trade and then just
took
x and gave it back to producers no won't
be sadder
if we give there is a little more than x
what if we did international trading
game producers x
plus 20 of 20 of z
then everybody wins that's the kind of
target the problem is we don't do that
all we do is let consumers have these
super cheap sweaters
so i get to go by this incredibly cheap
sweater
and people in north carolina's
livelihoods are destroyed
okay we don't compensate the losers and
the winners
don't notice they're paying five dollars
or ten dollars less for a sweater
but the looters losers notice they don't
have a job
so the problem is yes there's more
winning but first of all it's winning
among many more people by a small amount
whereas losing is by fewer people by a
large amount and that always gets more
political attention
and we don't have mechanisms in place so
don't put in
not we i started i can't but it's not
can't we could
we could easily address this there'd be
simple policy
what if we simply said there'll be a tax
on
there'll be a tax on all consumers of
international
on just a tax on consumers not of
international goods that would be like a
tariff
but just a general tax on consumers of
consumer goods that tend to come in
international trade so it says you know
tax on close
and we'll take all that money and we'll
redistribute it
to people who lost their jobs in the
textile sector help retrain them for new
jobs
or help pay their bills while they find
a new job then we could
literally deliver some of x and even
maybe some of z
to the producers but we don't do that
and that's the main reason
to answer your question why this
opposition of free trade is because
people
see the uh see the cost they don't see
the benefits
and well-off people like me who don't
need who could happily afford to pay
twice as much for a sweater
we just get these benefits we don't even
pay attention to whereas
you know typically lower income workers
because they compete in low-income
countries
lose their jobs and and uh and they
notice it
okay so that's one big reason the other
big reason
is that there can be socially damaging
routes
routes to comparative advantage
there can be socially deaths like social
imagery amounts to california
socially damaging routes to comparative
advantage that is there can be ways that
countries get to comparative advantage
that are not so happy so why does china
have low labor costs
partly because they got a billion and a
half people to work but partly because
workers are massively exploited there
work conditions are terrible and it's a
horrible life being a worker in a
chinese factory
moreover there's terrible environmental
conditions imposed by chinese production
in the u.s we have restrictions that try
to minimize
in some ways the environmental damage
done by our production they don't have
those in china
or india india is home to you know like
three of the top five
polluted cities in the world okay they
don't have those
so by creating their comparative
advantage
they may be doing damage that we don't
like just
just like we care about the fact that
consumers that we care about other
countries
welfare we might also care about the
fact that
that this free this free trade is
hurting other countries welfare
so a great example i've got a great
example a very relevant example
was a resource about lead poisoning in
china um
there was this battery factory you know
batteries are big business now
um that made lead acid batteries for
motorcycles and electric parks
electric bikes and basically they
operate under flagrant violation of
law environmental law that would just
dump the mercury and stuff they're using
like in the rivers and lakes all around
flagrant everybody knew it uh and 233
adults and nine nine children
were found at lead in their bloods up to
seven times the safe amount
and they're basically going to be you
know lives will be destroyed by this
okay and this is a big issue in the
negotiation of nafta
and a big reason a lot of people on the
left don't like international trade
is because they fear for the welfare of
people are being affected
so in nafta when it was negotiated in
the early 90s
there were some protections for workers
there are some protections
basically the idea was mexico if you
want to sign this you got to put in some
protections
to sort of raise the standard of living
your worker and improve your environment
so once again um there are ways to deal
with this
by put by saying look free trade where
we impose some restrictions
is still better than no free trade so he
might go in and say look once again
it's all about how you spend z okay you
got a bunch of money to spend
how you going to spend it some of the
way you can spend it is by compensating
the producers
another way you can spend is by saying
look we'll be willing to make it all
smaller have the world price be a little
bit higher
but make sure you have decent
environmental conditions and decision
wages for your workers as long as we
don't impose too high restrictions
we can still all gain okay so that's
another reason people don't like
international trade on the other hand
we taught we taught the story of the
child workers in vietnam
and how free trade and rice were it was
better for them because their parents
got richer
and had them work less and put them in
school so it's not clear which way this
goes but that's certainly another
concern
okay and then finally there's the issue
which is i think paramount in this
administration
which is trade policy
trade policy as a tool of foreign policy
trade policy tool foreign policy look
consider where we are with china today
okay there's a host of reasons to be
angry with china now some are irrational
the trump's
administration obsession with trade
deficits i've explained repeatedly is
irrational
okay it's the pikachu fallacy okay but
some of it's rational okay china
we operate under something called the
world trading organization once again
coming the other questions another
chance to try to kind of cartelize the
country and
set a catalyze the world and set a fair
a set
of fair trading rules the world trading
organization
china repeatedly violates the rules set
up by the world trading organization
for example under those rules china
should allow free
much freer sales of u.s goods in china
but they sort of implicitly restrict
them not not on paper but in practice
they set up lots of practices
which makes it harder to set up sell us
goods
they also do a lot of significant
industrial espionage and
espionage and stealing our industrial
secrets so i want to do that for example
is china has a rule
that you cannot have a solely owned
subsidiary in china
if you want a subsidiary in china has to
be jointly owned with a chinese company
which then will promptly take the ideas
and
pass them on and kick you out of the
country okay so
chinese engages some nasty practices
which are bad
for the uh which are certainly bad that
may be good for china they're certainly
bad for u.s self-interest
and that's true that is unambiguously
true the question is
what's the right response and the trump
administration argues the right response
is tariffs
the right response is to punish china
through tariffs
for their bad behavior an economist
virtual economists say that's the wrong
response there is literally
less than one percent of economists who
believe who who agree with this policy
just a few of them happen work in the
trump administration but basically the
end of the day basically
virtual economists agree it's a bad idea
and that's for three reasons
the first reason is our standard reason
that we think trade is good
we think we're hurting ourselves by
imposing tariffs on chinese goods all we
do is hurting ourselves or making people
pay more for stuff
why do we want to do that moreover
we're causing a trade war china is now
imposing tariffs on our goods which
hurts our producers
so our farmers for example um
are going to suffer because they'll be
harder to sell our farm goods in china
because the new tariffs they've imposed
so the standard arguments we have here
still hold we like free trade because it
expands opportunities
and if we try to limit it other
countries will respond in a way which
further restrict opportunities
so that's the standard reason economists
are mad about this
okay the second reason is it's sort of
hard to
do this it's hard to use trade policy
tool of foreign policy
because it's not even clear what's made
in china and what's made in america
anymore
so if we build the car in america but
the parts are made in china
is an american car a chinese car
oftentimes those things which are
shipped to china back to america then
back to china or vice versa
so it's not even clear what's a chinese
import or export and what's u.s imported
export these are
these are blurry lines now now once
again that's all because the efficiency
of production
basically what we've done over time is
we sort of
micro we sort of uh disaggregated
production
to more and more efficient components it
used to be one guy made the whole car
now we recognize there's certain parts
that are made more efficiently in china
certain parts made more efficiently
in cambodia more efficiently in the us
more efficiently in germany and we put
them together
what that does that makes international
trade super messy to understand
but it makes the world better off it's
just further increasing comparative
advantage of specialization
but it makes it harder to decide what's
a chinese good one to us good
so that's the second problem and the
third and probably the single most
important criticism economists make is
this is a really
silly thing to do by yourself the us
is big but we still represent a minority
of chinese exports okay where is it a
large share but still a minority
as long as china can still sell to other
people
okay and they're making plenty of money
off their practices against us
they might not stop now they're they
prefer to sell to us
but if you think on the one hand they're
making a ton of money ripping us off
on the other hand they'll still get to
sell 70 80
as much the rest of the world once they
adjust things then maybe they'll be like
fine
we're happy to let you do that you're
just cutting off your nose to spite your
face
but if we get the whole world to
coordinate and say you violated the
norms of the world trading organization
we're now all going to set up trade
restrictions on china then they feel the
pain
so the other reason economists oppose
this is moving unilaterally
on trade just doesn't make sense
okay if you want to try to get to deal
with these problems
you need to through coordinated response
okay
now let me be very clear this is a very
very hard issue okay economists try to
make it very simple with our
surplus diagrams and stuff like that but
it's a super hard issue
okay nonetheless it's an issue
where your bias in thinking about it
should be
towards the basic bias of economics
which is if we can expand opportunity
sets that's a good thing
and the real challenge is twofold how do
we expand opportunity sets in a fair way
and two how do we deal with compensating
the losers as opportunity sets
advance and this is something we'll
spend a lot of time on after
thanksgiving
it's how we redistribute in society from
one group to another
okay now let me get some questions on
this is sort of a topic yeah
sometimes the u.s will suggest that like
sanctions are imposed
against that country and i was wondering
if you know anything about how
that tends to work in terms of welfare
like does
like do the sanctions tend to make the
country behave better
and then like like ultimately the world
is better off or are those also like a
bad idea
that's a really interesting question i
so let's think about sanctions in this
framework
so sanctions let's say one sanction
would be
you know it depends in the form of the
sanctions depends et cetera so
one section would be literally you have
to pay a bunch of money well then that's
just like a tax on the country
we just think about that think of the
country individual they're worse off you
and get some money in some sense it
depends on whether the sanction works or
not
so that's sort of the easy case is just
simply the trade-off of do you encourage
the behavior you want to encourage
versus what pain do you impose on the
country and how do you trade those two
things off
if they're a really bad acting country
you might not carry your imposing pain
on them
as long as there's some chance you get
the change of behavior you want you're
happy
but what if the sanctions limiting trade
well then you're hurting other countries
too
then it becomes a bit trickier so then
once again the trade-off is
three-piece i hurt the country i want to
hurt
but i heard countries i don't want to
hurt but i also may get a change of
behavior i want
so you have to wait you have to add
those three pieces and put them together
how do they put them together that's
exactly what we'll talk about after
thanksgiving you put them together by
thinking about a waiting function which
we call social welfare function
which awaits the well-being of all these
different parties and puts them together
okay a very related issue we haven't
talked to yeah i'm sorry go ahead
you know i i don't i think there's
almost no one who
makes any money by by underst by trying
to understand what's in the mind of the
current administration
so i i have no idea um i think
china is engaging in bad practices but i
also think it's good politics
and it's hard to know what what what's
the mix
but let's actually relate continue the
current administration's race and other
issues related to all this which you
haven't talked about which is what about
immigration
another you know i'm gonna stop before i
get to abortion
okay let what about what about what
about immigration
okay well immigration actually the
framework is very much the same
if if there are people who can
contribute to our society
by coming here then we are better off
by letting them in by the same logic
of specialization comparative advantage
if there are people
for example let's say u.s folks don't
want to pick our crops
and we don't want to clean toilets but
picking crops and cleaning toilets at a
low wage is a terrific opportunity for
someone from another country
then we could be better off by letting
them in
okay or let's say as this turned out to
be the true historically
the kind of person wants to take the
risk to immigrate to america
is the kind of person who often becomes
an entrepreneur and thinks up new ideas
much of the entrepreneurial ideas in
america have come from our nation's
history of immigrants
because who picks up and leaves it's
kind of a risky thing to do right to
pick up leave your home and leave and
come to this unknown place
and those sort of risk-loving people are
often the kind of people who sort of
think up new ideas and want to start new
businesses so for that reason
immigration
has traditionally been enormous benefit
to u.s economy
and i think today the general consensus
this is more controversial than free
trade
but i think the general consensus among
economists is that immigration on net is
good for the country
but there's traditional consequences
it's good for rich people because they
get
low paid people to pick their fruits and
do their lawn work
but it's bad for people who used to pick
the fruits and do the lawn work
so once again if we can figure out where
to compensate the losers
immigration is probably on that good now
it's more complicated
when we import a car it doesn't get
welfare or commit crimes
immigrants might get a welfare commit
crime so it's more complicated than just
free trade
so what you have to do in that case is
you have to look at the evidence
okay and the evidence is that immigrants
commit crime at a much
lower rate than comparable u.s citizens
and collect welfare at a much lower rate
than comparable u.s citizens so you
can't compare an immigrant to me
an immigrant is more likely to commit
crime or collect welfare than i am but
anger is also less educated than i am
that i'm not the comparable person
compare an immigrant to the person
they're sort of replacing the labor
market
a low-skilled us citizen okay immigrants
are less likely to collect welfare and
less likely to commit crimes than are
those people
so as a result those arguments don't
really bode well for restricted
immigration
on the other hand i think there's very
few people who say we should have a
totally porous and open border
okay because of illegal movement of
goods and because
there are we don't we don't want people
people are objectively criminal in other
countries they're also risk-loving we
honestly want them here
so i think this is a hard issue unlike
international trade where i think conus
would say just more is good
i think that immigration there are some
difficult trade-offs because
people come with a set of baggage that
goods don't come with
but i think economists would generally
say a lot of the same arguments apply we
just need to we
might need a more comprehensive policy
than we have when it comes to trading
goods